good and honorable Lady Of The Veil The
Veil Minister said to [ __ ] sheep instead
of women I can assure you the Sheep are
prettier
then why do you cut me so deep I've only
ever spoken the truth I see otah for
what he is
an unwavering and loyal a [ __ ]
it's a Crispin wasn't it so Kristen Cole
my prince ah yes apologies I couldn't
recall
perhaps my prince recalls when I knocked
him off his horse
very good to choose violence here is to
declare war against your king wonderful
race
apparently protection from a common law
I'm not so common
and not so common Hall then when we were
in near his age we [ __ ] our way
through most of the brothels on a street
of silk we were young men better have
first experience to be with me than some
more
and I made the answer for their crimes
even targaryens
who are you sir Gerald Royce Oven stuff
and I am making an accusation
you know in King's Landing men are made
to answer for their Slanders
bronze [ __ ] like you
we're nearer has delivered another son
I've got a mention of this one the Bears
are marked but entirely coincidence
you do not sleep well how can I with you
haunting my every move the guards can be
cruel
it seems they've been a special cruel to
you
my father and I missed you as at the
king's will and wisdom and how exactly
is that wisdom expressed be surprised if
he could remember his own name or if you
could King viserys's condition has
worsened since you saw him last
love your tongue for that
he can keep his tongue
and to vaman valerian May the gods give
him rest
I would rather feed my sons to the
dragons than have them carry Shields and
cups
for your drunken usurper [ __ ] of a king
she could have her answer now stuffed in
her father's mouth along with his
withered [ __ ] let's end this Mama's fast
King's Landing will have my answer on
the mother
foreign